and just breaking away from innovation
for a moment just a bit of breaking news
to bring you in the last few minutes
another mp has submitted a letter to the
1922 committee that's john stevenson mr
freeman do you have confidence in the
prime minister
yes i'm getting on with my job as his
minister for science research and
innovation and the truth is um
you know prime ministers are always
juggling uh tony blair was doing it
gordon brown was doing it it's a
full-time job i i would just say this um
in terms of the sue gray report i read
it very carefully and what really
shocked me actually was the culture of
staff drinking in number 10 which the
prime minister has rightly taken full
responsibility for i think most of us
were shocked
the odd gathering of people who are
working together whether in the nhs or
in the heart of the government bunker
at the end of a day for a slice of pizza
when they're already close is one thing
but it's the culture of routine drinking
at the workplace i think was so
extraordinary the prime minister's
rightly
expressed shock at that he's personally
apologized to the staff uh who were
treated badly um for raising it and he's
put in place and implemented all the
recommendations that sue grey has set
out
but in the end i think this is a prime
minister that won a huge mandate at the
last election and i was you know i was a
remainer but i recognized the mandate of
the brexit vote and i recognize the
mandate the prime minister has we've got
to deal with some very very serious
the ukraine war the cost of living
crisis we put 37 billion
extra now in this year big announcement
from the chancellor last week and
driving the economic conditions for
growth for people around the country in
the end the prime minister will be
accountable for this
i understand that colleagues are worried
and i respect their decision but i'm
busy getting on with the job in
government and making sure that we are
dealing with the cost of living crisis
and creating a high growth economy for
tomorrow